welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast today is going to be part two of
our discussion on popular diets and
common misconceptions in nutrition now
for today's episode I am going to be the
only host which leads me to a bit of an
update so as I mentioned in our most
recent episode the SBS podcast co-host
Union was on strike because they wanted
family contact to be reinstated despite
the obvious and direct threat to show
quality and show Focus I did make an
altruistic and generous concession and I
granted that request and it came with
only a modest pay reduction in order to
offset some of the damages that the
podcast would incur as we made that
change
so I granted that policy change uh and
unfortunately with some folks if you
give an inch they ask for a mile and
that's where we find ourselves currently
with the Union uh so after spending
Christmas time with their families
during the strike uh apparently they
decided that was something that they
want moving forward so they have
requested in addition to their previous
requests that they want Christmas day
off in the future uh now that to me is
kind of a Line in the Sand uh that that
would be fully incompatible with our
production schedule I don't want to get
too into the details about the behind
the scenes efforts here
um but this strike which I mean I've got
lawyers contacting me continuously
saying it's totally unfair totally
illegal but this strike continues and so
for that reason I am the only host for
today's show now we're going to get into
part two of this discussion but before I
do that I want to remind everyone that
if you like the show and you would like
to support it and support us in this
nasty battle with the Union uh there are
many ways you could do that you could
like rate or subscribe wherever you get
the podcast you can sign up for our
email newsletter by going to
strongerbyscience.com newsletter we send
out an email every Wednesday with a
really nice concise practical research
update we call it the research
spotlights we think you'll like them
very very much if you sign up if you're
looking for one-on-one virtual coaching
that is a service we offer at Stronger
by science you can learn more about our
coaching services and our very talented
team of coaches by going to
strongerbyscience.com coaching
if you want a discount on very
reasonably priced supplements you could
go to bulksupplements.com and use our
discount code it is SBS pod or sbspod
and that will get you a five percent
discount at bulksupplements.com uh you
could check out the mass research review
that's a monthly research review that
Greg and I publish along with Dr Eric
Helms and Dr Mike zordos keeping you up
to date with the newest research in
exercise and nutrition and then finally
you could check out macro factor that is
the diet app that Greg and I
co-developed along with a very very
talented team of colleagues it does have
a free trial so you can check it out
take it for a spin before you make any
kind of financial commitment
all right now let's move on to the
nutrition content for today's episode
just like last week gonna run through
some popular diets and while I'm doing
it talk about some common misconceptions
that are kind of related to some of
these diets for each of these I'm going
to try to discuss some pros and cons do
it in a pretty fair way I don't want
this to be the type of like vitriolic
myth busting episode where I'm just
really condescending the whole time it
doesn't make me feel happy it doesn't
make listeners feel happy so I'm going
to try to be fair
um and just really neutral about how I
discuss these diets and some of these
misconceptions gonna try to highlight
some positives and then also highlight
some negatives as well before I get into
that just like last week I want to
provide a little refresher just to kind
of
um kind of anchor us to some key
nutritional Concepts so when I talk
about a health promoting dietary pattern
I'm talking about
particular elements of a dietary pattern
a particular criteria you could say that
based on the best available evidence
seem to be compatible with a really
positive outcomes in terms of health and
wellness and Longevity so I usually
refer to two different tables of
criteria that when combined I think
provide a really nice overview of what a
generally
health-compatible dietary pattern looks
like so table one is the healthy diet
indicator criteria from 2015 it
basically advocates for eating a bunch
of fruits and vegetables keeping fat to
no more than 30 percent of total energy
keeping saturated fat to no more than 10
percent of total energy keeping
polyunsaturated fat between 6 and 11
percent of total energy keeping free or
added sugars to less than 10 percent of
total energy getting at least 25 grams
of fiber per day and getting at least
3.5 grams of potassium per day
now we can combine that with some
additional elements from the 2020
version of the healthy diet indicator
criteria that would involve in 2020 they
kind of updated and say explicitly try
to get plenty of beans and legumes into
your diet try to get nuts and seeds into
your diet try to get some whole grains
into your diet try to limit dietary
dietary sodium to less than two grams a
day try to limit processed meat as much
as you can and just try to have a a bit
of a just try to practice moderation
when it comes to unprocessed red meat
specifically now there are some elements
that as we're going to talk about
they're not hard rules right so I'm
going to talk about a dietary pattern
specifically the Mediterranean diet that
in many cases is going to go above 30
percent of total energy from fat and
that's okay you know we don't need to
check every single box to feel good
about the dietary pattern that we are
implementing but when possible we'd like
to to check at least several of these
boxes is when we're reviewing our diet
another one is dietary sodium
for most folks who are sedentary and
live in pretty climate controlled
conditions it would be pretty advisable
to keep sodium to know more than you
know two maybe three grams a day but
there are plenty of folks who do a lot
of exercise in the heat they're sweating
like crazy and they have considerable
sodium losses and so they they do they
do very well on on daily sodium intakes
well above two grams so these are
guidelines they are not rigid rules so
that's our starting point that kind of
helps us get our bearings when we are
evaluating a variety of different diets
and really closely looking at whether or
not they are a really good health
compatible dietary patterns so in last
week's episode or in the in the previous
episode we talked a lot about different
types of low carb diets um you know we
talked about
just general low-carb diets we talked
about the Zone diet the Atkins diet the
South Beach Diet ketogenic diets the
carnivore diet there's kind of a general
theme that a lot of those diets tended
to be relatively uh relatively low in
carbohydrate and in this episode I've
kind of grouped together some dietary
patterns that more fall on the low fat
side and also kind of tend to fall more
on the plant-based side so last week a
lot of lower carb higher fat diets with
a lot of animal products this week a lot
of low-fat higher carb diets with a lot
of plant products so there's some logic
to the way these are grouped together
but starting out I just want to talk
about low-fat diets more generally
so sometimes you will see uh content
creators medical professionals who say
hey go on a low-fat diet and they rarely
elaborate too far beyond that so when
someone says a low-fat diet
um if you're getting less than 30 of
your calories from fat that is often
considered a low-fat diet and if you're
getting less than 20 percent of your
calories from fat that is considered in
most cases a very low fat diet now when
we talk about what happens when you
adopt this type of dietary pattern one
of the things to consider is the impact
on testosterone and other sex hormone
levels so there are meta-analyzes
indicating that if you adopt a really
restrictive low calorie very low fat
diet it's probably not going to be
optimal for supporting high levels of
testosterone and other sex hormones that
there is a bit of an inhibitory effect
where circulating levels of those
hormones often does go down in response
two pretty aggressive fat restriction
so we might start to see that stuff you
know of course the total energy content
of your diet matters a lot but even
going down into the you know 25 20 15 of
energy range we'll start to see some of
those effects on uh sex hormone levels
now I don't want to overstate the
importance of those of those effects you
know sometimes people will see this
little you know totally physiologically
irrelevant negligible change in
testosterone and they'll really panic
and say how am I going to build muscle
with this drop in testosterone and in
reality you know testosterone it takes
pretty big changes in testosterone
before you start to see major effects on
things like libido sexual function uh
hypertrophy and strength gains body
composition more broadly it takes pretty
big changes in testosterone to really
move the needle when it comes to
practical outcomes but nonetheless a lot
of people say hey I'd like to support my
testosterone levels to the best of my
ability and it is worth noting that when
you start to get into these lower fat
diet ranges uh there could be an impact
on testosterone
now when we start talking about very low
fat diets we run into a different set of
considerations in terms of how low would
be too low so when we get really low
with dietary fat we might start to have
some concerns about our ability to
absorb fat soluble vitamins we might
have some concerns about whether or not
we're getting enough essential fatty
acids into the diet and they are
essential because our body cannot make
them that means we literally must get
them from our diet so if we are not
getting adequate essential fatty acid
intake for extended periods of time that
can lead to deleterious side effects
pertaining to our health and then a one
of the factors that you'll see
um you know I've looked into some papers
in the more medically oriented
literature where they put people on very
restrictive diets so it'll be like an
800 calorie per day diet using only meal
replacement beverages
and one of the questions that comes up
in this literature is if we're doing
these really extreme interventions where
it's you know we are giving the
participants their entire diet and it's
only 800 calories per day how much fat
do we necessarily need to put into those
uh meal replacement beverages that are
essentially making up their entire diet
and one of the things that they look at
is acutely uh over relatively short time
scales what is kind of the rate limiting
side effect what is the key side effect
that we really need to worry about when
it comes to our minimum fat contribution
in these Beverages and one of the things
that comes up pretty frequently in some
of these shorter term interventions is
gallbladder issues you want to make sure
that fat intake in these really extreme
interventions is high enough to avoid
any acute gallbladder issues and usually
it doesn't take a lot of fat to avoid
that in the short term you know you'll
see some of these papers saying as long
as we're giving these study participants
you know maybe 10 grams a day of fat we
seem to be able to Stave off some of
these gallbladder related side effects
in the acute sense now I would never in
my right mind tell someone that they
should eat 10 grams of fat a day that's
that from my perspective at very very
low way too low to consider a
sustainable long-term dietary solution
or dietary pattern so
when I look at a lower limit for
somebody's fat intake what I do is I
base it on their height so I encourage
people to take your height in
centimeters subtract 150 divide the
result by 2 and add 30. and that's going
to give you your daily minimum uh fat
kind of it's your lower threshold
basically for your daily fat intake you
should always be at that number or
higher there might be a day or two
throughout the week where you go lower
than that but your average daily intake
for the week should certainly be higher
than this lower limit so for example
let's say that you're 180 centimeters
tall
you would do 180 minus 150 that gives
you 30. divide that by 2 which gives you
15. add 30 and now you've got a lower
limit of 45 grams per day of fat so that
is my my kind of easy little heuristic
for calculating a lower fat threshold
and you know what I'm trying to do there
is make sure people aren't going so low
that we're you know that we have serious
concerns about fat soluble vitamin
absorption essential fatty acid intake
gallbladder issues things like that if
you're consistently at that level you
might notice some some fluctuations in
sex hormone levels but I'm hopeful that
you probably won't notice large changes
with that level of fat intake But
ultimately it depends on the individual
situation so this is just a basic
heuristic this is not uh this is not
medical advice uh and I'll be completely
candid when people ask me where those
numbers exactly come from it is figuring
out uh you know combining all this
literature like if you were to say go
find me in the literature the lowest
feasible fat intake that could be
recommended
like I said you'd probably say I guess
like 10 11 grams a day uh you know based
on these short-term interventions but
what I try to do with this heuristic is
combine studies that look at not just
you know acute gallbladder issues but
also you know how do we do our best to
make sure that we're not tanking sex
hormone levels or testosterone levels
and things like that so there there it
there's not some perfect study that
leads you to this exact calculation but
that's kind of a synthesis of my
interpretation of the literature again
making sure that we're definitely
avoiding those critical short-term
considerations in terms of side effects
but also seeing how do we put together a
heuristic that in most cases is going to
avoid you know physiologically
meaningful drops in sex hormone levels
But ultimately like I said if you're
hitting that bare minimum for fat intake
but you're on a super low calorie diet
there's not much we're going to be able
to do in terms of maintaining Baseline
levels of those sex hormone levels at a
certain point when you start to restrict
energy really aggressively those things
are going to move around a little bit
and not always in the direction that we
want
so when it comes to low-fat diets like I
said there are some considerations where
you want to say okay we definitely don't
want to go too low but broadly speaking
my per my perspective on low-fat diets
is very similar to my perspective on low
carb diets there are some very sensible
very sustainable ways to adopt a low-fat
diet and it it presents an opportunity
to reduce calorie intake for people who
are interested in losing fat or if
they're noticing some weight gain and
they simply want to get out ahead of
that and prevent further weight gain you
know if you're in a dietary position
where you want to reduce your calorie
intake for one of those reasons I think
whether you're doing it from a low carb
diet or a low-fat diet both are very
very suitable options for reducing
calorie intake and when we look at the
meta-analyzes
comparing weight loss or body
composition effects with low fat versus
low carb diets they seem to be very
equivalent it really just comes down to
are you eating enough protein to sustain
your fat free mass or your lean body
mass and at that point how lower your
calories getting that that's really
what's going to be dictating body
composition changes in a broad sense so
if you prefer a low-fat diet that's
great if you prefer a low carb diet
that's great the biggest thing is you
don't want to adopt a super restrictive
pattern that's incompatible with your
preferences now just like you know in
last episode we talked about some low
carb diets and I said low carb diets are
a great option but there are certain
types of low carb diets that get really
restrictive they have some of these
overly restrictive rules that are a
little bit arbitrary and so we don't
want to just be piling up rules and
guidelines that are hard to follow for
no reason so low carb diets are great
but that doesn't mean that every low
carb diet is great and I feel the same
way about low-fat diets low-fat diets
are an excellent totally viable option
for people who want to reduce their
caloric intake but there are certain
types of low-fat diets that just have
unnecessarily restrictive rules
and we want to avoid arbitrary
guidelines that make our life harder
without actually giving us much in
return
now there is a myth that is somewhat
related to low-fat diets and usually
it's a myth that is used to criticize
low-fat diets nowadays as low carb high
fat diets become more and more popular
we're seeing more people doing uh you
know ketogenic diets carnivore diets
things like that and it's not that
they're super prevalent necessarily you
know when we look at the population
level but the chatter online is getting
very very
um is definitely leaning in that
direction where a lot of folks are very
adamant about ketogenic diets carnivore
diets and other diets that are just
generally high in total fat and
typically in saturated fat as well
and so the myth here is that a lot of
people nowadays are kind of turning
nutritional science on its head they're
rejecting a lot of the uh scientific
consensus and they're saying actually
saturated fat is basically a superfood
you should be eating really really fatty
red meat as the base of your diet and
everything you thought you know about
low-fat diets being good for
cardiovascular health that stuff's all
fake uh and so once again just like in
last week's episode or in the previous
episode I want to refer people to a
three-part article series by Dr Alan
Flanagan over at Sigma nutrition it does
a very very good job of explaining the
scientific consensus of the
relationships between dietary patterns
certain nutrient intakes blood lipid
effects and then ultimately long-term
outcomes pertaining to cardiovascular
health so this idea that saturated fat
was wrongly demonized and it doesn't
affect blood lipids and blood lipids
don't affect heart disease risk there's
a lot of
either disinformation or misinformation
going around right now being used to
attack and critique low-fat diets and so
I don't want to be vitriolic and assume
that people making those arguments are
doing it with bad intent I to the extent
possible I really do try to force myself
to assume the best and really practice
the concept of being charitable with my
assumptions and just assuming people
that are putting out this content that
glorifies high intake of fatty red meat
and really demonizes low-fat diets I
assume the people making that content do
have the best of intentions and simply
uh see the literature differently than I
do but they they also see it differently
than the vast majority of people who are
very highly trained in nutritional
science and those types of claims are
really poorly supported by the evidence
so if you want to get an idea of the
scientific consensus that is in line
with the best available evidence I very
much recommend that three-part series by
Dr Flanagan now I want to get into uh
some specific types of diets that you
might see on the low-fat side of things
so one would be the ornish diet so this
is a very popular low-fat diet developed
by Dr Dean ornish
it is a lacto-ovo vegetarian diet and so
it includes uh some non-fat dairy
products it includes some egg whites in
moderation
um all meat fish poultry uh that stuff
is all off the table uh when it comes to
the ornish diet uh any kind of fatty
dairy products would be off the table uh
nut seeds avocados olives cooking oils I
mean pretty much anything with a
significant amount of fat in it is is
pretty much off the table so the idea
with the ornish diet is that it's very
very low in fat I think typically it's
around 10 percent of fat coming uh or
ten percent of total calories coming
from fat and so you might be wondering
so what do you actually eat on this diet
um it's largely centered around eating a
lot of fruit legumes vegetables and
whole grains it does
um to the best of my knowledge the
ornish diet does advocate for the use of
fish oil supplement elements for
essential fatty acid purposes getting in
marine-based omega-3 fatty acids and it
is part of an overall program that is
intended to um reverse heart disease or
reduce risk of heart disease and so it
includes elements if you look at the
whole kind of ornish plan it includes
exercise meditation yoga stress
reduction techniques and things like
that so my perspective is
if you are on the ornish diet but one
thing I do want to acknowledge I
appreciate the fact that it includes
other things you know instead of just
saying let's look at you know certain
nutrients it's saying well how are you
managing stress are you physically
active I think that's a good thing in
terms of being a comprehensive program
so I do want to give credit for that I
think overall if someone said hey I'm on
the ornish diet I wouldn't immediately
say wow that is an absolutely
catastrophic eating pattern but I will
say the the fats are lower than I would
typically advocate for being only 10 of
total calories I usually like to stay
somewhere between 20 to 35 percent of
total calories coming from fat so this
does go below where I typically would
think of fat being in a diet those
percentages that I just mentioned 20 to
35 percent of course it depends on the
context you know whether calories in the
diet are high or low there's a lot that
goes into that but 10 fat is a very low
fat diet for sure
and another thing to keep in mind is
that this diet in my opinion is more
restrictive than necessary for health
related purposes so the idea that you
should for example cut fish or poultry
or avocados out of your diet entirely
to me it is difficult to argue that that
is an important restriction to apply for
health purposes from my read of the
literature having a diet that contains
fish poultry avocados nuts seeds things
like that some of these foods that just
have too much fat to really be
incorporated in the ornish diet at a
high level when I look at the literature
pertaining to those those uh food items
and those nutrients that they contain I
really don't see reason for concern
um you know and and I'll be completely
candid I eat a vegan diet but that
choice has very little to do with health
or performance it's it's a completely
extraneous set of factors dictating that
decision I never looked at my diet and
said in order to be healthy I need to
stop eating chicken breast or stop
eating salmon or stop eating off well
but I still eat avocado but you get the
idea
um the idea that you have to remove some
of these things from the diet for health
purposes just really doesn't doesn't
make a lot of sense to me if I'm being
completely candid so it's not that
adhering to the ornish diet would be
absolutely catastrophic generally
speaking but I do think the fat is lower
than I would prefer and I think there
are some unnecessary restrictions in the
diet that theoretically and practically
would would threaten sustainability and
feasibility I think when you adopt a
dietary pattern
you only want to have rules and and
guidelines that that truly do serve a
functional purpose that that are that
are not just beneficial but worth the
cost of of implementing the the rule or
the restriction or the guidelines so
ornish diet it's okay but but it's not
really my preferred approach to dieting
now that does bring me to the concept of
vegetarian and vegan diets so I'll
broadly sometimes refer to them as
plant-based diets uh sometimes I'll also
use the term plant forward diets which
is basically just a diet that might
include some non non-plant food sources
but is generally very plant heavy you
know so you might look at a very
plant-forward diet as being something
that it has a little bit of poultry a
little bit of fish but generally
speaking a lot of fruit a lot of
vegetables a lot of whole grains a lot
of beans and legumes and things like
that so plant-based diets to me that
that kind of is an umbrella term that
includes vegetarian and vegan vegan
diets
and I think it's a natural transition
from the ornish diet you know which does
um you know the ornish diet is lacto-ovo
vegetarian so it's a nice little
transition into these kind of
plant-based diets so a vegetarian diet
can take many forms like I said it could
be a lacto-ovo vegetarian diet like the
ornish diet and that means that dairy
products and egg products lacto and OVO
Dairy and egg those are included into a
vegetarian or plant-based eating plan if
you're doing lacto-ovo vegetarian there
are also people who take way different
approaches they might only include Dairy
but not egg they might only include egg
but not dairy some people are vegetarian
plus fish you know so there's a lot of
stuff that falls under this umbrella and
then there's also the term flexitarian
which to the best of my knowledge
basically describes someone who most of
the time generally eats a plant-based
diet but sometimes you know they'll have
some animal products here and there
foreign
or some meat products here and there so
uh vegetarian diets you know that's kind
of the lay of the land and then of
course the most strict application of
the vegetarian diet would be the vegan
diet which is pretty you know a pretty
categorical rejection of any
animal-based products there are some
foods that kind of fall into gray areas
on vegan diets I've seen some very
Lively debates among vegans about
whether or not you can eat things like
oysters or snails or honey even uh and
and so there are some foods where people
kind of boil down into philosophical
arguments about the more more so the
ethics of eating a particular food
product but generally speaking vegan
diets are pretty straightforward if you
know if it comes from an animal you
generally don't eat it so when we look
at these vegetarian and plant-based
diets in the literature they generally
do quite well across a wide range of
Health outcomes when you look at a
variety of different
um mortality factors and chronic disease
outcomes generally speaking you know
plant-based diets either do just as well
as omnivorous diets or in some cases a
little better than omnivorous diets but
that's not to say that vegetarian and
vegan diets are not without shortcomings
so for example
if you're on a vegan diet it's probably
a good idea to lift weights now
it's probably a good idea to lift
weights if you're not on a vegan diet
but the the relative importance May
indeed increase when you're on a vegan
diet there was a recent study that I
reviewed in the mass research review
where they were looking at bone micro
architecture in omnivores versus vegans
and what they found was among people who
did not lift weights there were some
potentially noteworthy differences where
bone micro architecture was less
favorable in vegans and and it's very
possible that categorically cutting
Dairy out of the diet could be a key
contributor to that observation
so for people who did not lift weights
bone structure and micro architecture
looked better in omnivores meaning they
had lower risk of you know lower
theoretical risk of fracture
osteoporosis things of that nature
however when they looked at people who
lifted weights regularly the differences
between omnivore Wars and vegans that
Gap closed very very quickly very
noticeably so it does appear that if
you're on a vegan diet
first of all you want to make sure
you're still finding good bioavailable
sources of things like calcium and
vitamin D you want to make sure you're
getting plenty of protein some of these
dietary factors that impact bone health
and Bone architecture but you also want
to make sure that you're lifting weights
because lifting weights any kind of
resistance training is going to provide
a great stimulus for strengthening bones
and improving their micro architecture
so that's one thing to keep in mind with
a vegan diet now vegan diets if you're
on if you're consuming a low daily
protein intake they might not be as
suitable for supporting strength and
hypertrophy however
newer evidence within the last few years
has started to indicate as long as your
total protein intake is sufficient and
you don't have any massive gaps in terms
of any specific essential amino acid
vegan diets can support hypertrophy and
muscle strength and strength outcomes uh
just as well as omnivorous diets so if
we take a well-formulated vegan diet
that has complementary protein sources
and plenty of total protein it does just
as well supporting gains in muscle and
gains in strength when we compare it to
a similar omnivorous diet
so generally speaking there are a couple
extra things you want to think about if
you're on a vegan diet if you're on a
vegetarian diet if it's like OVO
lacto-vegetarian
um you know you've got plenty of uh you
know calcium vitamin D protein you know
high quality protein sources in the mix
um you know on that type of dietary
pattern from from my perspective uh from
a kind of Health perspective and
performance perspective an Ovo
lacto-vegetarian diet is is to from my
perspective not really discernible from
an omnivorous diet
um if you're getting a lot of your
protein from eggs and dairy from a
nutritional perspective you're you're
basically an omnivore as far as I'm
concerned I'm sure a lot of some people
will kind of push back against that I'm
sure
um but the idea is that there's not
really a huge distinction there it's
only once you start getting into vegan
diets where we say hey we really need to
make sure we're taking a closer look at
a couple key nutrients make sure we're
doing some things to support bone health
and muscle health things like that now
there there have been some concerns
about links between vegetarian diets and
depression
and so there are definitely
situations where you can look into the
literature and say I found an
observational paper uh linking vegan
diets to poor mental health and then of
course within those papers there's going
to be some
um uh you know some discussion about you
know is this a characteristic of people
who opt into vegan diets
um you know is there kind of a baseline
difference there or is it possible that
there is some nutrient shortcoming of a
vegan diet that is actually leading to
increased prevalence of depression uh so
there are you can find papers that
demonstrate that relationship and get
into some of those discussions but I'm
going to link two papers in the show
notes that from my perspective cast a
lot of Doubt on that assumed
relationship uh by which you know one
might say that the prevalence of
negative mental health outcomes is
higher in vegans there's a lot of um
contradictory evidence in that area when
you look at the most updated systematic
reviews and meta-analyzes they really
fail to support any strong link between
vegan diets and depression and and
Beyond establishing a strong link then
you'd have to then go further and say is
this link actually causative you know so
did people develop depressive symptoms
because they were on a vegan diet or did
people with elevated depressive symptoms
opt into a vegan diet so there's a lot
to unpack there in terms of first of all
establishing that this pattern exists
but then you have to go even further and
do more work to establish that the
pattern represents a causative effect of
the diet we're nowhere near having
evidence to really paint that entire
picture uh when I look at the literature
I really struggle to see uh significant
reason for concern pertaining to mental
health health outcomes as a result of
adopting a vegan or plant-based diet now
of course with any health outcome if you
have concerns about it you should
discuss it with a medical professional
this is just kind of my two cents
looking at the literature that's
available now there is a sub type of
vegan diet that sometimes gets popular
uh kind of Ebbs and flows in terms of
popularity waxes and wanes I guess it is
the raw vegan diet and so this is
basically a vegan diet where you're
eating uncooked Whole Foods really in in
a state that is as minimally processed
as possible so when you look at the
plate of someone who's on a raw vegan
diet you're going to look at it and
you're going to say okay there's some
you know some uncooked
broccoli on the plate some uncooked
peppers on the plate uh you know just a
bunch of raw vegetables and you know
they'll put in some you know some seeds
and nuts maybe some sprouted beans or
something but generally speaking the
idea is to keep things in uh you know as
unprocessed and untouched estate as
possible so minimal minimal processing
minimal cooking to the extent possible
so that's the concept with a raw vegan
diet
um
some people I think perceive that diet
as saying okay I'm going to take a vegan
diet which seems to be linked to some
positive Health outcomes generally
speaking and I'm going to take it a step
further and make it even better and even
healthier by taking this raw approach I
think that there are some issues with
that logic first of all
um there seems to be an assumption that
cooking these Foods makes them less uh
you know um less valuable from a
nutritional perspective and that is not
a broad statement that can really be
supported
um you know there are some instances
where cooking a food can cause a loss or
a degradation of certain nutrients but
there are also instances where cooking
or processing a plant-based food can
lead to better digestibility better
bioavailability of nutrients and it can
reduce the impact of what we might call
anti-nutrients so in a in a episode a
long time ago I talked about
anti-nutrients and I basically said you
know for most people you really don't
have to be super worried about it there
might be certain instances you know um
you know so uh there might be instances
pertaining to anemia where you might
look at someone who is symptomatic for
anemia you might look at their diet and
say oh okay you know there might be an
issue here with with some of the
bioavailability of the iron that you're
consuming so we might need to rectify
that but
in most cases anti-nutrients as I said
in a previous episode really aren't
worth worrying about within the context
of a typical dietary pattern because uh
we're usually not consuming enough of
them for it to matter that much and even
if we are consuming them uh a lot of
times we are you know if we're consuming
foods that contain a lot of them we're
usually just by you know typical dietary
practices and cooking practices we're
usually processing and cooking these
Foods in a way that greatly diminishes
the impact of whatever anti-nutrients
were initially present in the food now
if you adopt a relatively atypical or
uncommon dietary pattern like a raw
vegan diet those things could
potentially become more relevant in
terms of their their functional impact
on the diet so I don't want to fuel any
scaremongering and say oh man now you
need to really be concerned about
anti-nutrients but what I'm trying to
get at is a general rejection of the
premise that you take a vegan diet and
make it healthier or by saying well I'm
not going to cook or process anything I
I actually reject that that particular
assumption or claim and in fact I would
argue that if anything uh there are some
foods in a vegan diet that you would
prefer to uh to have some degree of
cooking or processing for the reasons
that I just listed so they're going to
be a lot of folks who say yeah raw vegan
diet new New Year's resolution adopt
this diet it's pretty extreme but it's
like you know healthy cranked up to 11.
uh I don't really see much of a benefit
with the raw element of that vegan diet
and in many cases it could actually be
viewed as a slight detriment nothing to
panic about but but probably not uh not
a sacrifice that's worth making in my
opinion uh speaking of things you're
going to hear about uh pertaining to you
know vegetable based diets uh you know
diets that are very very plant-based
things you're going to hear around the
new year uh every year you're going to
see a lot of folks talking about uh
juice cleanses or really just cleanses
or detoxes of any type and so I know a
lot of people in the stronger by science
audience are not thinking about that
when the new year comes but nonetheless
I I do feel
you know there's going to be so many
people talking about it in a positive
way I do think there is some benefit of
people kind of balancing that out by
making content that says hey let's go
ahead and address that um and kind of
bring things bring some of those claims
back down to earth a little bit uh you
know that we need a little bit of some
opposing viewpoints that are being put
out around this time of year so
as many of you are probably already
aware of there's really no science to
support these various uh juice cleanses
or or detoxes or detox teas could kind
of fall under this umbrella the human
body has very robust detoxification
mechanisms and those only need support
if you are really dealing with a a
diagnosed medical condition that that
would require treatment from an informed
Medical Professional if you're if you're
having issues with detoxing your body
Your solution is not in a new box of tea
it's not in a juice cleanse it's by
going and Consulting with a qualified
medical professional so
um generally speaking these juice
cleanses these detoxes these teas that
that claim to detox
um they're generally just not doing much
for you
now if you're just like having a juice
beverage on top of your normal diet uh
whatever no big deal you know probably
getting some extra vitamins and minerals
in the mix uh who cares right not doing
much but not a big deal but if you are
replacing your food intake with a really
aggressive juice cleanse or detox
program uh that's a bad idea you know so
you don't want to be doing anything
extreme that involves any of these
interventions I mean if it's just like
uh you know hey have this juice in the
morning and then you know combine it
with a reasonably healthy diet no big
deal
um but but you know there is potential
for some harm if you are uh getting rid
of all those criteria that we talked
about with a healthy dietary pattern and
instead you're drinking some some juice
or some tea so you definitely don't want
to do that
um you know in many cases when we when
we talk about these detox and these
cleanse products
um some of them are just a fruit juice
or a vegetable juice and it's like
whatever some vitamin and minerals that
that's fine some of them actually have
ingredients that uh that produce a
laxative effect
um and if that's the case you're just
giving yourself a stomachache for no
reason
um and I don't want to sound like a like
a smart ass but that is what it is uh
and I think these um these products they
often want to
induce that laxative effect so that
um it kind of amplifies the placebo
effect where you say
yeah I must be detoxing because boy am I
feeling something uh and you know I not
to get too graphic but you know people
can convince themselves there's a lot of
toxins leaving my body in a really
unpleasant way because of this this
laxative effect so
um yeah I'm generally not an advocate
for just giving yourself
GI distress and and so for that reason a
lot of these products I say yeah just
don't don't go anywhere near that so I
cannot think of a good reason to seek
out a juice cleanse program or a detox
product of any type
um but uh you know if you want to have
some vegetable juice on top of a healthy
diet go for it but but it doesn't have
to be some kind of expensive cleanse
product there are all sorts of uh
vegetable and fruit-based juice products
that could easily be incorporated with a
very healthy dietary pattern so I don't
really see any situation where you would
want to do any of this the only reason I
bring up the vitamins and minerals is
because I said you know I want to try to
at least highlight any tiny glimmer of a
positive attribute of any of these types
of interventions but just to be super
clear juice cleanses juice detox detox
teas I wouldn't go near them I can't
think of a good reason to do it if you
want to have some vegetable or fruit
juice within your diet just work it into
a more conventional dietary pattern uh
that brings me to another thing I'll
briefly address
um I mentioned sometimes these juice
cleanse interventions are framed as
essentially displacing your entire diet
and just working in a single beverage
that makes up the entirety of your
nutrition and that brings me to the
topic of really any single food diet so
like I've seen things on the internet
about like a grapefruit diet or a
cabbage soup diet just really any single
food diet and you could even lump in you
know extreme applications of the
carnivore diet where it seems like some
people are advocating to just eat beef
like just eat the muscle of cows
um any single food diet is gonna be a
bad idea there are many very good foods
out there but there is not a single
perfect human sustaining food uh the
closest thing you're going to see to
that in the literature is going to be a
well-formulated meal replacement
beverage and those are sometimes used in
scientific intervention and randomized
controlled trials I mentioned earlier in
this episode you can find many studies
where researchers will say we are going
to give you an 800 or 1000 or 1200
calorie diet
that is going to be only made of this
specific meal replacement beverage drink
three of them a day 800 calories that's
your diet for the next 12 weeks so there
are some products that aim to do that
but usually that's going to take place
in the context of a medically supervised
short-term scenario so like I said it'll
be a 12-week intervention where you're
under you know constant you're
constantly in contact with the research
staff which has a trained Medical
Professional who is looking out for any
unfavorable side effects of such an
extreme intervention so any single
food-based diet whether it's a food or a
beverage I would categorically reject
outside of some of those medically
supervised scenarios you might find a
situation where under medical
supervision you are given a diet that is
either fully or heavily dependent on
meal replacement beverages but like I
said and for those people those meal
replacement beverages are are a miracle
I mean they're really really important
um you know I there are some instances
where especially if you look uh
in the short term recovery period from
things like bariatric surgery uh where
the overall capacity of the stomach is
very limited and it you know there are
some considerations pertaining to
nutrient absorption you know some of
these single meal replacement based
interventions uh can be you know really
important and helpful medical
interventions for people who need them
um you know sometimes it's very
difficult to navigate that acute period
recovering uh I I was part of a study
where we were you know doing an
intervention pertaining to that kind of
early phase recovery from bariatric
surgery uh it's immensely challenging to
say okay we've got these vitamin
absorption considerations that are new
we've got very limited stomach capacity
how do we actually deliver the nutrients
that are necessary
um so that they can be absorbed and and
support all the nutritional needs of the
patient while also making sure that that
it's not a volume of of liquid that is
just completely untenable
um you know stomach capacity is so
limited it can be very difficult to even
get down a few meal replacement shakes a
day and there's actually a kind of best
practices that list out the volume of
food and beverage and the type of food
of beverage that you reintroduce in
phases after bariatric surgery so I know
for a lot of people that's going to be
extraneous information that's not
pertinent to them
um but like I said I want to highlight
some positive attributes of things that
I still generally don't advise so there
are some medical applications where we
might say for a short period of time we
are going to do an intervention that's
based on meal replacement beverages as
kind of a single food diet but in terms
of developing a sustainable Health
compatible overall dietary pattern I
would strongly encourage people to avoid
any single food diets outside of a
recommendation from a medical a
qualified medical professional
foreign
as the first and only Fitness podcast
with a steadfast commitment to
traditional Family Values we know that
protecting families is important right
you are Eric but I will note there are
some things that are even more important
than protecting traditional family
values and the moral fabric of our
society that's right Greg it's important
to protect families but it's even more
important to protect corporate entities
that's why I joined the Advisory board
for the Sports Nutrition Association
Along with trusted Fitness Pros like
Danny Lennon and distrusted arch nemesis
like Eric Helms the Sports Nutrition
Association is the home of Sports
Nutrition they are dedicated to ensuring
the sustainable prosperity of the Sports
Nutrition profession and they offer a
unique Pathway to robust insurance
coverage for your Sports Nutrition
business simply put it's the best way to
protect the corporate entities that are
closest to your heart and I should note
if you're an individual soul proprietor
providing Sports nutrition services and
not a corporate entity the Sports
Nutrition Association can help you out
as well that is correct all insurance
plans are handled individually on a
case-by-case basis regardless of how
your Sports Nutrition business is
structured but even if you don't want
insurance coverage sna membership comes
with a bunch of other perks and
advantages the Sports Nutrition
Association is the only Global
professional sports body that has a
defined standard for Sports Nutrition
scope of practice for its members this
ensures that members maintain high
standards in their practice so that the
public can always trust in the quality
associated with the services of an
accredited Sports nutritionist through
the Sports Nutrition Association if you
already meet their minimum education
requirements you can become an
accredited Sports nutritionist today if
you don't meet those education
requirements yet you can enroll in the
certificate program in applied Sports
Nutrition that allows you to become a
provisionally accredited member upon
completion to learn more about the
Sports Nutrition Association head over
to
www.sportsnutritionassociation.com today
today's episode is sponsored by the
Sports Nutrition Association and
stronger by science LLC sincerely
appreciates their support
so we've talked a little bit about some
of these plant-based diets some of these
lower fat diets and now I want to talk
about another category of diets that
you're probably going to hear about a
lot as we approach you know New Year's
resolution season so that's going to be
uh kind of a a category of diet advice
that falls under the umbrella of fasting
so you're going to be hearing a lot
about time restricted feeding
intermittent fasting and then extended
fasting Windows where people will say oh
yeah you should be doing a 24 48 72 or a
72 hour fast where all you have is water
so I want to talk a little bit about
these different meal timing strategies
and and fasting strategies so the first
one
the least uh intense application of
these fasting strategies would be time
restricted feeding
now you may hear what I'm about to
describe and say oh that's intermittent
fasting but there's actually
unfortunately a bit of a gap in the
nomenclature when we compare the fitness
industry to the academic research on the
topic so if you are eating every day
then you're not doing what most well
that's too much of an oversimplification
I'll put it this way intermittent
fasting within the fitness industry got
really popular as basically just having
a short feeding window every day so
basically you have a four or six or
eight hour period of time every day
where you eat and then the rest of the
day you are not eating you are fasting a
lot of folks in the fitness industry
call that intermittent fasting but
that's actually based on the research
more compatible with a term that we call
time restricted feeding so you're eating
on a daily basis you're eating pretty
similar amounts of food on a daily basis
but you're constraining it into a
limited time window where you consume
all your calories for the day and this
could take um frankly
a very simple uh a a very simple form so
there is some research on the concept of
just skipping breakfast and uh to some
extent you could kind of let that fall
under the umbrella of time restricted
feeding because in most interventions
where they tell people to skip breakfast
the rest of their dietary pattern stays
pretty consistent they're having lunch
and dinner at the same time generally
speaking so what you're doing is you're
taking a broader feeding window
breakfast lunch and dinner and you're
condensing that into a shorter feeding
window which is just lunch and dinner
um so so I I think that the breakfast
skipping literature can be used to help
us form inferences about time restricted
feeding but the most common application
of time restricted feeding especially in
the fitness world is what we call 16 8
time restricted feeding and what that
means is every day you've got a 16-hour
window where you're fasting and an
eight-hour window dough where you're
feeding so all of your calories might be
consumed for example between noon and 8
PM right so outside of those hours no
calories at all you can still drink
water and things like that but within 12
you know 12 noon to 8 PM that's where
you're eating all your calories and you
can adjust that window wherever you want
you can start that eight hour window at
night eight at nine a.m if you'd like or
7 A.M and there is some research to
indicate that there might be just the
slightest advantages associated with
moving a restricted feeding window
earlier in the day rather than later in
the day don't want to get too into the
details on that because it's a a pretty
nuanced research subject but generally
speaking time restricted feeding the
most common application is an eight hour
feeding window and you can put it
wherever you want throughout the day
another common one is 24. so 20 hours
fasting four hours feeding same exact
thing but your feeding window instead of
being eight hours is only going to be
four now with time restricted feeding uh
the 16 8 version really not bad at all
and to be frank even the you know the 24
version uh you know not not that bad in
terms of dietary approaches what you'll
find is that when you when a lot of
people condense their feeding window
they tend to eat fewer calories overall
because it's just kind of rather than
just kind of grazing on food throughout
the day if you only have a four hour
feeding window you can imagine for
example an extreme application
if you were only eating one meal a day
and you normally had a 3 000 calorie
diet uh when you're eating you know your
normal eating schedule
if someone said okay from now on just
eat one meal a day it's gonna be really
hard to eat those 3 000 calories at a
single meal unless you're really trying
to you know if you're making it like a
really nutrient dense milkshake just to
try to get the calories in you might be
able to get it done but generally
speaking if you tell people hey don't
change your food intake that much but
just just have fewer meals kind of
squeeze them into this tighter feeding
window most of the time people are going
to report that they start consuming
fewer calories as a result of that they
start losing some weight they start
losing some fat mass and they really
don't feel super hungry throughout the
day because they kind of forget about
eating during the fasting period Then
they do their feeding period it's this
huge influx of calories I mean it's a
really massive meal if you're having all
your daily calories in you know one or
two meals in a short feeding window uh
so it ends up being a very feasible
strategy for passively reducing calorie
intake now when you look at studies
where calorie intake is very closely
matched because the researchers insist
upon it then what you find is outcomes
are pretty similar for most you know
things that Stronger by science folks
would be interested in you know most
health and fitness related and
performance related outcomes tend to be
pretty similar when both groups are
eating the same total amount of calories
in the same macronutrients but what
you'll find is
when you talk to the people who are in
the time restricted feeding group they
say man I could barely get those
calories in and people in the the more
normal typical dietary pattern would say
yeah that was fine I I wasn't really
full I wasn't really overly filled by
those meals so it really comes down to
hunger and satiety management now I will
say
um when we talk about protein timing
there is pretty good research to
indicate that when possible if your main
goal is to support hypertrophy muscle
growth increases in strength and
performance ideally you would like to
have probably at least three meals
spread throughout the day with at least
a couple of hours between those meals uh
so I I would suggest that if you are
really prioritizing muscle growth and
you want to fully optimize muscle growth
you probably don't want a feeding window
that is much shorter than eight hours
because that allows you to have a high
protein meal at the beginning beginning
the middle and the end of that eight
hour feeding window and you should be
able to essentially optimize your gains
within that feeding schedule if you're
not optimizing you're getting very very
close there there are you know
randomized controlled trials where
people Grant Tinsley has done some
really phenomenal work in this area uh
couldn't have more respect for a
researcher than the respect I have for
Grant Tinsley his his work really is
phenomenal and this is one of his focal
areas we've talked about his work in the
areas of body composition and uh you
know metabolic rate prediction metabolic
rate assessment but time restricted
feeding is really his sweet spot
and uh his work has indicated if we look
at people on a typical feeding pattern
we compare it to people who are doing an
eight hour time restricted feeding
window uh both both approaches have
similar effects when it comes to muscle
growth and strength increases so uh 16 8
seems to be great uh the more you
condense that and you get into maybe a
four hour feeding window where you only
have two protein feeding opportunities
or if you even get even closer down to
one meal a day you start to limit the
likelihood that you are fully optimizing
your progress in terms of muscle growth
you can still make great gains don't get
me wrong you can still make excellent
progress but you are probably not in a
position where you're well suited to
optimize your progress in terms of
hypertrophy
um now I am going to link in the show
notes a research Spotlight that I did a
while back about time restricted feeding
uh and how you can optimize time
restricted feeding if if you are really
adamant about trying to really
prioritize gains in muscle and strength
now getting away from time restricted
feeding oh one thing I do want to
mention since I brought up breakfast
skipping some people ask about that a
lot it comes up around New Year's you
know people have heard that breakfast is
the most important meal of the day and
you really really shouldn't skip it I
will say if if you look at
um the majority of the breakfast
skipping literature where they they do
these really hands-off interventions
they say Hey you
don't eat breakfast you keep doing your
thing and that's kind of the the extent
of the intervention because they want it
to be very ecologically valid they want
to know what happens when all you do is
tell someone don't eat breakfast and
usually what they find is calorie intake
at lunch and dinner and snacks
throughout the day does go up a little
bit uh when people skip breakfast but it
doesn't go up enough to actually match
the calories that they would have eaten
at breakfast so what you generally find
in the literature is that when you tell
someone to skip breakfast a lot like
when you tell someone to have an
eight-hour feeding window the net impact
on calorie intake tends to be a small
reduction because people are just kind
of forcing more calories into those
other other meals they're feeling more
full at those other meals and their
total calorie intake for the whole day
tends to go down a little bit so I just
wanted to address that because there's
going to be a lot of new years content
about whether breakfast is super
important or whether or not you should
skip it you can skip it and it's it's
not going sometimes people will suggest
that if you skip breakfast you're just
going to be starving all day and you're
gonna overeat like crazy and end up over
consuming calories the literature
generally does not support that that
idea so breakfast skipping eight hour
feeding Windows both totally viable not
critical but viable uh now moving on to
intermittent fasting
intermittent fasting in the academic
literature is not the same as time
restricted feeding usually with
intermittent fasting you're going to
have certain days of the week where for
the whole day you are either totally
fasting and and only consuming fluids
you know beverages that are non-caloric
or you have certain days of the week
where you have a massive reduction in
your energy intake so like there might
be a couple days a week where you say
those are my fasting days and even if
I'm not totally fasting I'm dropping my
calories to like 25 of what they would
normally be for example so there are
different approaches you can take when
it comes to intermittent fasting one
would be alternate day fasting and again
when I say fasting days it could be a
true fast with no calories or it could
just be a massive reduction in calorie
intake for a specified day but you you
could do alternate day fasting where
every other day it's normal calorie
normal calorie day with you know a
typical calorie intake for you and then
a fasting day typical calorie day and
fasting day you're just alternating back
and forth another popular approach is
what they call the 5-2 diet
where you are picking two days a week to
be your fasting days and the other five
days you try to maintain your typical
calorie intake so you're not trying to
ramp up your calories on the five days
to kind of offset the two fasting days
what you're trying to do is saying I
want to introduce a calorie deficit but
I don't want to feel like it's super
hard every single day of the week so
I'll keep doing my normal stuff for five
days and then those two fasting days are
where I'm really going to make my
progress in terms of establishing a
weekly caloric deficit now generally
speaking these types of intermittent
fasting strategies seem to be very
viable they do seem to help some folks
reduce their calorie con calorie intake
across the week on average and so it is
a viable weight loss strategy when we
control for total weekly calorie intake
they don't seem to be better or worse
for just total weight loss but I will
say two things first of all
there are are some concerns if if you're
working with someone or if you are
someone who is predisposed to uh
what we might call disordered eating
patterns if you are kind of susceptible
to eating disorder pathologies uh if you
have potentially some psychological
relationships to your food intake that
could be viewed as as somewhat um
somewhat concerning or problematic you
might not want to jump into a dietary
pattern
that involves cyclical restriction of
calories it could theoretically lend
itself to a situation where you are now
easing into the concept of having really
high calorie days and then kind of
purging and have you know really really
aggressive restriction and you don't
want to get into that swinging back and
forth of really high calorie intakes on
your feeding days excessive restriction
on your fasting days it could lead you
down a road that is not really optimized
for your kind of psychological State as
it pertains to food intake so if you
sense that you have high uh
predisposition to disordered eating
patterns I would not recommend venturing
into intermittent fasting without
medical supervision and working with a
qualified uh professional whether that's
a a registered dietitian a psychologist
or a counselor who is really focused on
nutrition general concepts with their
Psychological Services you want to make
sure that you venture into that very
lightly if you do it at all you'd want
to make sure that you've got someone on
your team there who can help you keep an
eye out for some of those problematic
patterns the second thing I would
mention is there is evidence suggesting
that these patterns might not be best
for optimizing muscle mass or lean body
mass like I mentioned we generally want
to spread our protein
and at least three ish feedings
throughout the day and of course if
you're having full fasting days it's
going to be difficult to be doing the
things we need to do to support muscle
growth nutritionally during those
fasting days and so it doesn't mean you
can't make any progress if you're doing
intermittent fasting but it does mean
it's going to be more challenging to
optimize muscle gain when you have you
know every other day or two days a week
where you're really not able to support
the energy demand and the protein
demands that would support optimizing
muscle growth so again I'm going to link
a research Spotlight that addresses five
two intermittent fasting and some other
intermittent fasting strategies and how
they relate to supporting muscle growth
so intermittent fasting just to kind of
wrap that up it is a viable approach
that seems to help some folks lose
weight probably not the best possible
approach for maintaining or building
muscle and if you feel like you have
have susceptibility to disordered eating
patterns it's probably not a road that
you want to go down without uh you know
having someone in your corner who is
clinically trained to look out for some
of the signs and symptoms of problematic
approaches to eating
now the final thing I want to mention uh
when it comes to fasting is there are a
lot of folks these days who are talking
about doing really prolonged fasting
periods not as part of an intermittent
fasting strategy strategy but just for
specific health benefits that they link
to prolonged fasting so they're not
saying hey you should do these fasting
days because it'll help you kind of
establish a caloric deficit they're
saying you need to do these fasting
periods because fasting itself has huge
health benefits and they're usually
linking it to a process called autophagy
now autophagy is kind of a natural
process where
um you know our cells remove
unnecessary or dysfunctional components
it's it's kind of we can think of it as
a process of recycling cellular
components that are either damaged or
unnecessary or you know you get the idea
it's the body kind of going through and
doing a tune-up and getting rid of some
of the uh the stuff that that can be uh
that can be discarded or recycled so
initially
if you look at how autophagy was
discussed over the years it was
initially seen as something that occurs
during starvation and it was and of
course it does occur during starvation
and it was seen as a means of kind of
efficiently recycling uh important
things that we need to survive in the
context of starvation but now it's clear
that that it is kind of an ongoing
process that is just kind of part of
homeostasis of just managing cells to to
keep them functioning their best so I'm
certainly not suggesting that autophagy
is not an important cellular thing or
cellular process however
there are a lot of folks who say listen
autophagy is important it creates you
know it's an important process for cells
to kind of do their housekeeping and
their recycling of damage components
um and so in order to make autophagy
happen you have to do these really
complicated or really arduous fasting
protocols that sometimes are are quite
long in duration now based on the
literature I've seen uh these uh fasting
Protocols are very overhyped and really
not supported by good science uh again
I'm not saying that autophagy is not
important but when I look at the
evidence the most pertinent evidence
that's relevant to human beings
and I look at what do you need to do to
facilitate
autophagy and essentially maximize the
theoretical benefits of autophagy
occurring when I look at what you would
need to do to do that I think there are
a few things you could point to first of
all maintaining a BMI or a level of
adiposity or a body fat percentage that
is combat compatible with good long-term
cardio metabolic Health that seems to be
one thing that would help being
Physically Active doing structured
exercise on a regular basis and avoiding
over nutrition so avoiding just eating
way more than you need in terms of
energy content those things
seem to be sufficient for essentially
maximizing the theoretical benefit of
autophagy occurring
um you know so when someone is in a
caloric deficit and they're losing fat
mass and getting down to a BMI that
might be more compatible with optimizing
their cardio metabolic health and
long-term risk when they're doing that
autophagy will be ramped up and there's
really no reason to complicate that by
doing these excessively arduous fasting
protocols
um and so these fasting protocols do
they operate up regulate autophagy uh
sure they probably do but but is there
actually going to be a benefit of that
above and beyond the typical autophagy
that we see by doing those basic things
I mentioned previously uh probably not
and could there be some uh uh some side
effects and some Adverse Events that
occur from really arduous fasting
protocols without medical supervision uh
my answer would be yes um I I would
never nudge someone toward a fasting
protocol that was particularly
aggressive or ambitious in the absence
of medical supervision
um so generally speaking if you're
thinking about doing some kind of long
fasting protocol for health benefits I
would discourage you from doing that
because of the risk for Adverse Events
and because of the it goes back to the
thing I've been saying a lot over this
two-part series which is
um you know if we're making a sacrifice
and it's really challenging we need to
make sure we're really getting something
for it we don't want to be doing these
challenging sacrifices that reduce the
sustainability reduce feasibility reduce
quality of life we don't want to be
doing these things if we're not actually
getting serious payoff from these
sacrifices
so now I want to move on here and just
talk about well we've talked about
different diets and some of their
shortcomings but what are some good
dietary patterns that that serve as a
good starting point so like I said a
good diet what we're trying to do is
basically check many of the boxes in
those those two sets of healthy diet
indicator criteria so we talked about
all those different criteria that go
into a generally healthy dietary pattern
we want to check a lot of those boxes to
the extent that we can
now we can do that with you know like I
said just broadly speaking a low carb
diet a low fat diet those are both
totally viable options totally feasible
but we want to avoid the really
restrictive versions of them that start
to pull us away from some of those
healthy diet indicator criteria now if
someone were to ask me what are some
good starting points in terms of named
diets like if someone was like Hey I'm
looking at this kind of list of 10
popular diets which one should I start
with if I really want to choose a named
diet and I don't want to go through the
work of looking at the healthy diet
indicator criteria and kind of piecing
it together bit by bit one place I would
start would be the Mediterranean diet
and this is a diet that was inspired by
the eating habits of people who live in
the Mediterranean region initially it
drew largely on the Cuisines of Greece
Italy France and Spain recently it's
Incorporated some other Mediterranean
cuisine scenes turkey Lebanon Syria
North Africa Portugal so I know a lot of
people criticize the Mediterranean diet
in the way it's been popularized because
it it it has been a bit biased in saying
the Mediterranean diet pertains to like
these one or two countries in the
Mediterranean region and sometimes it is
a bit uh exclusionary when it comes to
see these other Cuisines that are very
much in the Mediterranean region so I do
want to acknowledge that that is a very
valid criticism of the way the
Mediterranean diet has been popularized
but when I talk about the Mediterranean
diet
I I really talk about it because of the
medical literature that seems to
consistently show that it's linked with
some pretty positive outcomes uh both in
uh prospective cohort trials and
randomized controlled trials and when we
look at the basic elements of a
Mediterranean diet it usually features a
lot of consumption of unprocessed
cereals uh legumes olive oil fruits
vegetables and then moderate consumption
of things like fish Dairy and meat
products and what's really interesting
about the Mediterranean diet you know I
mentioned previously the healthy diet
indicator criteria we do not want to
treat it as a list that we have to check
every single box all the time and the
reason I bring that up is with a
Mediterranean diet when you look at the
trials that do it you'll often see that
fat intake can get up to 35 even 40
percent of total calories and the
healthy diet indicator criteria say well
generally you might want to keep fat to
less than 30. so the Mediterranean diet
does violate 1 element of those healthy
diet indicator criteria nonetheless as
an overall dietary pattern it checks
many of the boxes and it still does a
really nice job when it's actually put
to the test and some of the uh the
longitudinal trials that investigate it
so Mediterranean diet
you don't have to follow every single
ruling guideline but it does offer a
good starting point when you're trying
to put together a healthy dietary
pattern and you don't want to just
totally start from scratch one myth I
want to address when it comes to the
Mediterranean diet like I said it is
typically a pretty plant forward diet
not vegetarian by any means but you know
a lot of plant foods and there are a lot
of vegetable oils that find their way
into it now one of the most common
vegetable oils in the Mediterranean diet
is olive oil and olive oil usually
people don't beat up on olive oil too
much it tends to be associated with a
lot of positive outcomes but there is a
myth that's getting more and more
popular that vegetable oils broadly
speaking are very bad for you
and people are generally focusing on
linoleic acid which is the main omega-6
polyunsaturated fatty acid that is found
in a variety of vegetable oils now lime
oleic acid is not found in the same
amount in all vegetable oils and so
people mostly focus on seed oils as
being uh really
um
as being oils that have high
concentrations of linoleic acid so
people are saying hey stay away from
these seed oils they're toxic they're
terrible for you the people who are
really outspoken about seed oils really
leave olive oil alone generally speaking
which is pertinent to the Mediterranean
diet mostly because olive oil compared
to other vegetable oils doesn't really
have a ton of linoleic acid I'm going to
link to an article that really pushes
back against a lot of this Panic that's
happening about seed oils and other
vegetable oils generally speaking the
claim that's going on here is that
vegetable oils and specifically seed
oils contain linoleic acid which
increases the susceptibility of LDL
cholesterol to oxidize and theoretically
you know they're making the argument
that this increases risk of
cardiovascular disease
and of course people have branched out
and gone into all sorts of tangents
about all the the various ways that they
think uh seed oils are terrible for you
uh and along those same lines they say
you know what what is way better would
be saturated fat so instead of having
these uh plant-based vegetable oils you
should be eating a lot of fatty meat
that's kind of how the the arguments
tend to go
um I don't want to get too deep into the
Weeds on this particular set of
arguments like I said I'm going to link
to an article by Nick Hebert that um
that goes into a lot of these arguments
one by one and I think very soundly uh
provides compelling evidence to uh to
really
really debunk a lot of those Concepts my
general take is when you look at the
literature on omega-6 fatty acids and
linoleic acid in general uh when you
look at you know this broader broader
evidence of vegetable oils omega-6
polyunsaturated fatty acids linoleic
acid specifically
when you start to work your way up the
hierarchy of evidence and you get away
from the stuff that's happening in Petri
dishes and cell cultures you start
working into
observationally when we look at people
who eat a lot of this stuff does it look
like they're regretting it the answer is
no when we go into prospective cohort
studies and we say when we actually have
people eat more of this do we see
deleterious outcomes the answer is
broadly no and in fact there are studies
indicating some pretty notable benefits
When you replace saturated fatty acids
with polyunsaturated fatty acids in the
diet
so when you look at the highest quality
evidence with the most uh relevance and
generalizability you start to see that a
lot of these arguments about vegetable
oils being bad they they really do start
to frankly Crash and Burn they really
break down uh quite quickly
um you will see some some papers out
there saying you know
omega-6 polyunsaturated fatty acids in
the western diet we tend to eat a lot of
those and we don't eat enough omega-3 uh
polyunsaturated fatty acids and so
people talk a lot a lot about this ratio
of omega-6 to omega-3 and how we want to
get that ratio lower so that there's
less omega-6 more omega-3
when I dig into that literature and my
assessment is that the only issue with
high omega-6 and low omega-3 is the fact
that there's just low omega-3 and
usually the way you would want to
intervene there is by simply making sure
you're getting plenty of omega-3 fatty
acids in your diet they are essential
you do need them so you want to make
sure you're getting plenty of those
um you know so you could just take a
simplistic approach and say hey I'm
going to eat plenty of nuts and seeds
maybe some fatty fish I should be
getting plenty of Omega-3s into my diet
if you really want to fully optimize
omega-3 intake you might consider
specifically seeking out Marine sources
so people talk a lot about fish oil
specifically EPA and DHA it's important
to note you can also get EPA and DHA
which we typically call fish oil you
could also get that from algae so some
people like vegans like me supplement
with algae oil instead of fish oil so
EPA and DHA do tend to have some pretty
positive effects in the body you want to
make sure you're getting some of them if
you can usually you know when you look
at the research people say getting at
least 0.3 to 0.5 grams a day of combined
EPA and DHA appears to be a positive
thing for a whole bunch of different uh
health and wellness outcomes still
unclear if there's any benefit of going
higher than that if you look at the
literature some people or some studies
will involve supplementing with uh
instead of 0.3 to 0.5 they might go up
to one maybe even two grams a day of
combined EPA and DHA for a healthy
person I don't think there's really
reason to go beyond that uh one to two
grams per day might even be Overkill you
will see some studies where they go
really high dose and they're talking
like six or eight grams a day of fish
oil uh from my perspective that seems to
be Overkill and I really don't see that
as being a necessary thing uh so uh I
just wanted to kind of address that myth
because it's probably going to be on the
top 10 list of the big myths that are
floating around around New Year's
nutrition content so seed oils vegetable
oils really no reason to be worried
um and yeah so the Mediterranean diet is
is a good starting point if you're
looking for a healthy dietary pattern
another one that comes to mind is the
DASH diet and dash stands for dietary
approaches to stop hypertension so it
was developed to prevent and control
hypertension but when you look at it
it is just broadly a pretty solid
overall dietary pattern so it's rich in
fruits vegetables whole grains low-fat
Dairy Foods uh it includes meat fish
poultry nuts and beans
um but but they aren't really at the
Forefront of the diet they're kind of
hanging out in the background and it
generally involves limiting uh sugar
sweetened foods and Beverages and
keeping red meat and added fats to a
minimum so typically when you look at
the diet you're going to see it's going
to be somewhere in the ballpark of about
20 percent of calories coming from fat
when researchers try to really dial it
in and do it by the book
um so one of the things that is
interesting about the DASH diet is it
does check a lot of those boxes of the
healthy diet indicator criteria it is a
pretty well-rounded approach there are
some elements that are more restrictive
than necessary you know so if you dig
into the details about like potassium
and sodium there might be some
restrictions that aren't really
necessary if you don't have elevated
blood pressure so there are some some
guidelines in there that might be a
little bit
extraneous or excessive but it's
generally a pretty flexible dietary
pattern that like I said checks a lot of
the boxes that we're going for here so I
think the DASH diet is a really
excellent starting point in terms of a
healthy diet pattern uh one of the
things that's worth noting
is if you look at the U.S dietary
guidelines from 2015 to 2020 uh they
they basically mentioned three healthy
diets that are recommended broadly
speaking the Mediterranean diet the DASH
diet and then also a vegetarian diet so
I when we talk about these kind of basic
diets to adopt for a healthy dietary
pattern I do want to also in line with
that you know I mentioned Mediterranean
I mentioned Dash I don't want to be
biased but the third diet that tends to
be mentioned is just a generally
plant-based vegetarian diet these like I
said previously they tend to do quite
well in the literature so I've already
talked about some of the positive
attributes I've talked about some of the
nutrients of concern things you want to
keep an eye on with a plant-based diet
but I just want to reiterate here the
reason that I suspect that this was
included as a healthy dietary pattern is
because most people when they transition
to a plant-based diet they will increase
their intake of you know high fiber
grain products
vegetables fruits things of that nature
so for a lot of people there is a net
benefit when it comes to the overall
change in dietary pattern and they will
be reducing things like processed Meats
really high intakes of fatty red meats
things like that so a lot of people will
have a net Improvement in their dietary
pattern when they say you know what I'm
going to try a vegetarian diet but you
know some people don't necessarily do
that right so some people will say okay
when I adopt a vegetarian diet I'm not
thinking how am I going to incorporate
all these nutritious plant-based Foods
they're thinking okay no more meat and
that's it so I mean you know you could
just have Oreos and almond milk all day
and say yeah I'm a vegetarian it's great
it's not really going to be a healthy
dietary pattern and some people they
will kind of gravitate toward refined
very snackable grain products uh really
carb heavy diets when they switch to a
vegetarian diet and actually they find
that their cardio metabolic Health
gets worse rather than better in the
short term I don't want to be uh I don't
want to paint with too broad a brush or
cause any kind of unwarranted concern
about plant-based diets but a
plant-based diet is so broad that you
know it's in important to acknowledge
some people will have a net Improvement
in their dietary pattern but some people
will have a net downgrade in their
dietary pattern when they just say I'm
going to adopt a vegetarian diet so it
is important to keep that in mind and
one other thing I do want to mention
I want to make sure I'm going out of my
way to correct for any bias that might
be Brewing within me so I am on a vegan
diet okay so obviously I think highly of
plant-based diets but it's important to
recognize I I made that decision for
reasons unrelated to nutrition I think
that plant-based diets and even vegan
diets are viable alternatives to
omnivorous diets but that doesn't mean
that they are necessarily more healthy
and what I mean by that is if I look at
someone who is is eating you know
poultry and fish as part of their diet
and they say Eric do I need to stop
eating chicken breast and salmon in
order to be optimally healthy my answer
would categorically be no if we look at
the literature on you know some of these
animal-based products there's no reason
for us to say that you should for health
reasons remove them from your diet or at
least I don't find the evidence to be
compelling so if two people come to me
and one one person says I'm on a totally
vegan diet the other person says I'm in
on on I'm on an omnivorous diet and
that's hard to say which which features
a lot of poultry you know a lot of fish
a little bit of of lean red meat here
and there if someone were to ask me
which of those two people has the
healthier diet I genuinely have no idea
I'd have to really look at the overall
dietary pattern and say
that vegan diet what does it look like
that omnivorous diet in totality what
does it look like I know they're eating
some poultry and fish a little bit of
red meat here and there but just from
saying you know one diet is vegetarian
the other is omnivorous I can't really
say that one's better than the other and
if someone is eating uh you know a dash
diet or they're they're eating a
Mediterranean diet and they're going by
the book and they come to me and say hey
Eric do I need to remove all the poultry
from my diet to make this healthier I'd
say no and if they say if I remove the
poultry will I become healthier the
poultry and the fish for example I'd say
I I don't really think so uh you know so
it's important to recognize that
plant-based diets are a great
alternative but it's not fair to say
that the best healthiest diet is one
that contains no animal products that
would not be an evidence-based statement
it would not be in line with the current
scientific evidence so uh in summary if
you are
an omnivore and you have a preference
for higher fat intake you just like the
food options you like how it makes you
feel I would say a Mediterranean diet is
a great starting point for a dietary
pattern if you're an omnivore and you
have more of a preference for higher
carbs and lower fat I would say the DASH
diet would be a great starting point and
then of course if you're not an omnivore
if you're a vegetarian then you would
want to adopt of course a plant-based
eating pattern but in terms of the other
characteristics of the diet you might
want to model some of the other
characteristics
around the Mediterranean eating pattern
or the dash eating pattern and say I'm
going to do Mediterranean or I'm going
to do Dash and the only difference is
I'm going to swap in plant-based protein
sources instead of animal based those
are kind of the three starting points
where I would say if you just wanted a
simple recommendation of where to begin
that those are places where I that I'd
give a lot of consideration of course as
I mentioned frequently if you're going
to make any major changes to your diet
carry patterns you should consult with a
qualified medical professional rather
than some random podcaster but um but
but based on the evidence those are the
three areas that seem to be really
really compelling
so I want to wrap up with a summary here
uh plant-based diets are totally viable
options for lifters and non-lifters
alike and plant-based diets do tend to
be associated with plenty of great
health outcomes but it would be
inaccurate to suggest that adding animal
proteins to a diet makes it
categorically worse from a health
perspective a plant-based diet is not
necessarily healthier than a well well
constructed omnivorous diet what we know
is that humans can Thrive and perform
well on a wide range of diets with
varying amounts of plant-based Foods so
there is a ton of Plex a ton of
flexibility for you to pursue a diet
that's right for you your goals and your
preferences if you have no idea where to
begin the general patterns associated
with the Mediterranean diet and the DASH
diet offer very good starting points in
terms of a healthy dietary pattern when
it comes to fasting strategies the
perceived benefits are usually way
overblown
and extended fasts can be unfavorable
when it comes to muscle mass and
performance nonetheless there are some
appetite related advantages to
time-restricted feeding and certain
intermittent fasting strategies and if
you're really focused on optimizing
muscle and strength you can do a Time
restricted feeding pattern with an
eight-hour feeding window and that seems
to be totally suitable for supporting
improvements in body composition and
improvements in performance
uh now finally before I end this episode
I hope you'll once again afford me the
opportunity to make a Shameless sales
pitch on behalf of macro factor which is
the diet app that Greg and I
co-developed along with a remarkably
talented team of colleagues as you're
considering putting together a dietary
pattern and revisiting your diet choices
in the new year I want to
reinforce the fact that macro factor is
very very flexible
and it really can facilitate whatever
dietary strategy you're planning to
adopt uh first and foremost it is a
remarkably fast and efficient food
logger it's got a huge verified database
of foods so you don't have to worry
about whether there's fake or incorrect
entries in the food database
on top of that database there's really
convenient workflows where you can
create custom Foods create custom
recipes and you can even share your
custom recipes with others so whatever
your food preferences are macro Factor
can absolutely handle it when it comes
to the coach programs our coach programs
within macro Factor they have many
settings and they range all the way from
ketogenic diets to low-fat diets that
tend to be high in carbohydrate and with
within each Macro program you have
plenty of flexibility so you can choose
for example your level of protein intake
there are four different levels that you
can choose from so there's a lot of
flexibility there in terms of your
macronutrient distribution your protein
level your specific food choices but if
you want even more flexibility you can
Branch out from the coached programs
and you can get into what we call
collaborative mode where you get
continued guidance about your daily
calorie Target but you have a little
more flexibility with custom macro
targets from day to day and you can even
do a fully manual program that is a
hundred percent customized to your exact
liking in addition I should mention in
this episode I talked a little bit about
time restricted feeding intermittent
fasting the macro Factor food log is
relatively relatively unique in the
sense that it takes the form of a
timeline so what that means is you can
Implement a ton of different meal timing
strategies within macro factor which
would include various types of time
restricted feeding in addition you can
actually designate fasting days within
macro factor and so if you are using
some type of intermittent fasting
strategy macro Factor can certainly
accommodate that and the algorithm will
still be working perfectly as it should
uh so in short macro factor is designed
to be your diet sidekick it provides
guidance support and analytics that you
need but it doesn't infringe upon your
ability to make your own decisions and
to chart your own course toward your
fitness goals so whatever dietary
strategies you intend to pursue in the
New Year macro Factor can absolutely
Provide support so
if you want to learn more about macro
Factor head over to macrofactorapp.com
you can learn more about the app which
is available for Android and iPhone
devices you can also check out some of
our content there Greg and I have been
putting in a lot of video a lot of
Articles and even we're starting to do
some videos over at macrofactorapp.com
so if you want even more content from
the stronger by science Universe be sure
to head over and check it out so that
does it for this episode as always
thanks so much for joining me for
another episode of The Stronger by
science podcast we'll be back soon with
another
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules we
hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
can sign up for the free newsletter at
strongerbyscience.com newsletter or just
go to the stronger by science homepage
and click the free programs button at
the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our Facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional once again thank you for
listening and we will be back soon with
another episode of The Stronger by
science podcast
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]